people often point out my hair so let me
indulge you in a recent lifestyle
transformation Behold our sponsor MD
hair spectacular Ensemble I'm cautious
with hair products but MD hair has me
singing a different tune the magic it's
personalized baby ref and easy quiz to a
scalp analysis it's like they peered
into my soul and knew exactly what my
hair needed first this shampoo ah it's
not just about cleaning it fights hair
thinning then the conditioner fortified
with keratin and silk peptides makes my
hair feel like it's walking the red
carpet the serum targets my hair loss
making it thicker stronger and oh boy
this Marine collagen helps with hair
skin nails everything less of the
supplements more than 20 active plant
complexes yes please just a dab of this
a splash of that and voila I'm not just
ready for the camera I'm ready for the
world and folks because I love you just
as much as I love my luscious locks snag
your first month of MD hair at 70 off
with my promo code real 70 because you
and your hair deserve the absolute best
thank you once again MD hair for
sponsoring this video
that ever if you skipped it you better
rewind it and watch it guys we got
ourselves
this episode seven today we've loved the
last two episodes can't wait for this
John how are you pun it oh goodness
Michael I am Star Wars all right that's
DC since ladies and gentlemen use the
force to leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated subscribe click that
Bell you know phone reaction finale is
up thank you to all of joining us on our
patreon page lastly wait till after this
reaction where we unveil our new real
rejects exclusive Ahsoka sure it's not
this
it's awesome after the reaction I'll
unveil it
whoa the Senate symbol is back protected
the new Republic By ignoring direct
orders no I protected the new Republic
By ignoring you yeah you've had it out
for her since day one of us seeing you
there was no proof of any coordination
between the scattered and dwindling
number of Imperial forces what about the
conflict on Mandalore hey hey oh get in
was a warlord acting on his own there's
no proof of a greater conspiracy and
thus no immediate threat to this
Republic as foolish to assume General
sandula be court-martialed for
disobeying a direct order
no
Leia see the review identification I
hear 3PO oh my God yeah
honor to Chancellor with respect I am
here on behalf of Senator Leia Organa
oh so close so close spiritual Cameo
they honorable
all right this is wonderful to finally
see some politics of the new Republic
with Leia sanctioned generals
reconnaissance mission to citos Senator
ziono had held a vote against such a
mission without her oh oh no cannot
admit evidence of this kind from a mere
Droid I'm not just any Droid bro the
chopper again
further concerns to her directly in her
role as leader of the defense Council ah
yeah baby that seems to settle the
matter oh God I love later remain
unsatisfied Senator CNN Moe isn't
certified
Court dismissed the 1970s aesthetic too
here is my programming and my pleasure
to be of service General cindola
I don't know what you and Leia are
playing at but I know she did not
authorize your mission
she did after the fact eventually
how real is the threat of throw ing's
return oh so real we have to prepare for
the worst and hope for the best
[Music]
good Mantra to live by generally
dreams and Madness oh I like it sums me
up in a nutshell
uh-oh oh yeah and then they just
Massacre them all
oh yeah oh you look good
hello there oh
oh my goodness dang in this war you will
face more than just droids oh this is
from Tales of the Jedi General Grievous
massage
like
as your master it's my responsibility to
prepare you I did such a good job
practice these forms often
or at least more than I do
we get separated or something happens
you need to be able to make it on your
own
but be afraid
[Music]
I know you can do this is so good oh she
can
man he really is great back in that role
he made Plenty or more of these
recordings this was his last one
season finale he was a good master
if only he were here to hear you say
that they find the enemy
and we find Sabine directing to the
point isn't it that's my style
everyone's just hunting each other
assuming the star whales have brought us
to the correct Galaxy I think the odds
are pretty good no no in fact they're
terrible
mother at least acknowledging this
the worst part is I hope you are right
love how cantankerous who Yang is we are
exiting hyperspace now
it's amazing how they all avoid crashing
into each other
something's wrong there's a star
destroyer waiting for them
[Music]
whoa
Whoa man star Taurus is crazy yeah I
cannot wait for this expansion pack
oh fascinating
oh man since I Minefield him
oh this is sore this is really sad to
watch
oh wow at least the whales are providing
some cover yeah at least forget about
their lives
oh never mind
this feels like Star Wars man
outnumbered and outgunned
out mined oh my God every once in a
while you gotta mow with air like this
is this feels like Star Wars
oh
oh yeah
now this is POD races wow
well we found the enemy
God those rings are so foreboding a sick
I'm going to make for the debris field
come on where's that optimism
yes this is like an adventure
time
through the Boneyard with you
I'm having way too much fun with this
right now
[Music]
wow this is great how cool oh nicely
done
oh I came here I look just so good it
was seem as a good time was alive and
well after all here's everything The
Inquisitor
[Music]
so a master was General Anakin Skywalker
I am such a fan I mean he had worked
with him once I feel like thrawn was one
of the few that figured it out I think
there were hints that he figured it out
right why not allow them to follow we
shall lose them in the debris field
you're quite right of course Jedi are
very good at hiding
they've been practicing that for years
yeah we are getting to know our
adversary that's why we love them and if
she's anything like a master she'll be
unpredictable dangerous oh yeah put her
on a path around choosing so that no
matter which directions it takes are you
clever cunning bastards we've always be
one step ahead of her I'm so glad that
they're not doing him dirty at all is
true to himself this is great when
Ahsoka was finally introduced to live
action she said where's Grand Admiral
thrawn they're finally about to meet
wow
elephant graveyard
they're about to meet Scar from The Lion
King yeah he prepared I will run a
scound to see if I can locate lady Ren
Ezra Ezra the empire was defeated Battle
of Endor
Emperor died that's what people say
somehow Deb's training recruits and
Harris commanding they finally mentioned
Zeb I was beginning to think we'd never
find you how did you
still haven't told him oh my god well we
could talk about something else I guess
no no let's not Dodge this one
Ahsoka took me on as her Apprentice she
what why
such a good reaction where is Ahsoka is
she coming
dude unveil it come on
complicated
yeah yeah Ezra's too good of a dude now
it's not the time for being all unspoken
there's subtext and then there's just
not talking about it there's a waiting
for later when you could be doing it now
wow this feels very Two Towers I was
gonna say they're on the wargs yeah
going down lies hidden within the
graveyards
fight huh
yes oh are they gonna make the bones of
the chant those bones
oh is this some kind of ancient uh
Morgan Ellsworth actually contributing
or is she just like playing along with
the band yeah
he's trying to like keep along with the
prayers and I cannot locate lady red
should I try again
no do or do not there is no try we don't
need a scan you the force do you think
your bond is that strong
you almost rhymed
dreams and Madness
whoa hasn't been all bad obviously I
made a few friends it took me in when I
really needed help set me up at this pod
got married had a kid with one
oh
I see her
[Music]
I uh I know where Luke is
there oh it's like the planet oh that's
really oh the Lord of the Rings
influence is so very apparent this time
around especially I don't know
feeling
that's where it all starts
familiar
Nostalgia don't worry I know where we're
going wonderful
wonderful well no way oh
wow this POV shots always get me
[Music]
you're desecrating the remnants of the
Dead contact The Fighter Group and have
them re-engage the
oh my God I like to hunt I love it yeah
this chess game we also have Balin right
behind him nice I mean there's so many
moving puzzle pieces right now
oh boy no it's time for a standoff
I don't like them at all
what if the gray power bailen's been
seeking has been the naughty
Turtle crap people because of being ran
and Ezra Bridger
take your place in the coming Empire
yes Dad you won't help
your ambition drives you in One
Direction my path lies in another
you've become so much more mysterious
dude that's for Jedi trials impatience
for victory
will guarantee to feed things Anakin
really needed to hear before losing all
of his limbs
here
go Expendables go
if Lord bailing proves capable we may
yet win the day not today Grand Admiral
thrawn it is not this day
ah I think this might be our first time
seeing those in live action
correct me if I'm wrong internet
we definitely have not seen those in
live action
I think there's a great suspense build
up to this man it's really fun
oh it's just gonna get his lightsaber
back Cowboys and Indians
my back
[Laughter]
ha ha
oh nice shot
[Music]
don't taste my vehicle
strange high-speed chase Sabine looks
good though
[Music]
oh Ezra do some Force stuff
no he's he's gonna we're saving it give
him a chance to Woopa first
yes Rock them in shells are strong or
out this is just like when the 300
banded their Shields together
oh my oh Ezra's gonna kick some ass Ezra
show them what you're made of all right
space Moses let my people go
well now he has to join who's that she's
like you but left your sense of humor
we better get ready
lock the door
go
dude he just fits like right in he's
great he's so phenomenal he's great he's
perfect
[Music]
but notice the giant ship
attack standard Jedi Mission protocol
States yeah we're in a different galaxy
yes of course just remember what
happened last time you got the timing
wrong I didn't I feel terrible no
precisely when she means to
either this has an Intergalactic
swashbuckling Vibe oh yeah
it's almost like Solo in the western oh
that's some Clone Wars jumping right
there
be on the same team didn't expect to see
you again
God the music disappointed no aroused
straw
s
I'm excited for this rematch High Noon
baby
oh wow
what's the plan
yeah
do you think you do your thing cause two
lightsaber take it you keep it what I
don't need it besides you've been
training I don't what does he have the
new Power no I'm serious take it I gave
it to you it's yours now please take a
blaster no
[Music]
oh my God he's like a Tai Chi fighter
now he's like it man yeah
yeah
oh yes forces with me
[Music]
yes no but I don't want bailin to die I
know nah there's more to him
oh you're so badass it's got to be the
coolest thing getting your face shot
through lock savers
says an actor
it's like EO in The Matrix Four yeah
no oh that was a close one oh he got his
zero
nobody makes me bleed my own hair
[Music]
oh
Savage
Oh my God the Rippling on the plate damn
it's like similar to Invader versus Riva
oh
come on I wonder if thrawn's gonna
attack all of them
don't defeat me perhaps
I don't have to my confidence and Poise
I love it
wow not bad
who yang
I'll get you next time Gadget
I just love him
God does more acting with everything he
just said
a couple of seconds
I love Ezra so much it's cool to see him
not rely on Weaponry at all he just got
more I was here that was a brilliant
brilliant Choice yeah to work with what
he had which is just the force my side
is short one mastery
I'm gonna get a penalty and lose 10
yards where's balance gone
yeah
nice
she really should have some more best
car
[Music]
close the window
wait wait
we could
talk I love Ezra don't you want to take
us as prisoners as prisoners
I got money
[Music]
[Applause]
this might be a function she doesn't
even whip out the lightsaber
same my dude same we're with you
no they can actually shoot at least
it was some witch Troopers
damn he's got some strong force powers
nice Iron Man
flash Mandalorian
what a rare sight
sight almost like the Jedi of old
speaks for such Nuance in his delivery
you can hear the admiration one might
even call this first match with Turner a
success 4K we learned a lot we shall
soon leave this forsaken place
today time her way out time no come on
pay attention
time is very much on our side now and I
should keep it that way
let's run out the clock go Force choke
time The Season's almost over
run away
oh you should go Shen
love that stare
Surrender Your Weapon
oh what is about to happen
I can help you
my other Apprentice
she's not gonna
do what I okay
but there was a glimmer in there
interesting
she gonna go with them or is she going
around separate I'm telling you we're
we're getting the full team up
no Oh I thought you were dead
stop talking I supposed to read have a
moment
yeah there we go just act with your face
[Laughter]
I thought she was dead
clearly I was wrong
let's just brush past that one all right
now I just gotta grab a couple space
wheels and we're good
[Music]
friends
oh they're so adorable
[Music]
this is my son guys getting a feeling a
good feeling about this I think I might
be going home after all
you've earned it
but they got one more mission
oh how's everything going to do that all
right ladies and gentlemen now before we
go into anything my sister she has drawn
this shirt and is now officially on our
website
www.rejacknationshop.com
here it is the Ahsoka snip snip shirt do
you get it huh
how do you get it it's totally
realize
because she's got scissors
do you understand the joke the
lightsaber scissors nothing says real
rejects Like a Star Wars themed
vasectomy yeah right that is the future
nip snip
those tubes come on it's funny
it's adorable and you you know you know
Greg is is Lucas or Edward Scissorhands
gonna sue you first quiet
we also got this shirt and we got that
shirt and we got that shirt I like that
one oh my God we got so many more and it
is too many sure undoubtedly undoubtedly
one of the top three ways to support
this is my getting yours just get it do
it get it took a long time to actually
put that one together gotta catch them
all so get it go get it thank you guys
I'm excited about it it literally just
got finished yesterday so it's gonna be
um in the mail uh it's on the it's in
the mail right now for me and I'm hoping
that I have it by last episode
I can't wait I won't talk about anything
else nothing happened in this episode I
mean that's a terrible God no I really
enjoyed it I had so much fun let's rank
it everyone all right Michael out of a
10 what would you give it I would give
this episode a a strong 8.5 all right
John what would you give it oh this is
like a Niner for me wow I mean it's just
uh yes wow okay okay fine what do you
want me to do now hold down eight points
no what are you Star Wars Theory no
what's the right answer quick uh I'm
going to go with
uh I'm uh I don't know
it's not like I don't have any
complaints no it's okay John it's okay
I think I'm uh
I mean I'm an 8.5 as well it's a solid
number there are a couple of things I
thought the internet would say you're
also an 8.5
I'm a tad let there's a couple of things
I was like ah that kind of feels a bit
of a letdown because they built it up
but I want to talk about the things I
liked can I choose the topic the first
topic of today's conversation Greg this
is your show I'm just a guest here
that's right that's what I say before
they walk through that door I says don't
you forget it follow my lead and you
don't ever try to take commands
Ezra Bridger man uh this was an episode
that
really I thought I thought we would
probably actually spend more time
getting to like catch up with Ezra
Richard and and hang out with him more
like oh what's going on I thought it'd
be the way how they dedicated a lot to
thrawn in the last episode I thought
that that's what this episode was gonna
be more like but they're still kind of
keeping a bit of an air mystery around I
I even feel like what they revealed with
um how in tune he is with the force even
more so now than ever yeah I think
that's some great off Screen development
because it just makes the most sense of
what this guy would do uh in the
meantime basically and I feel like
there's a higher evolution of that even
more to come you know I I'm excited for
that and I just love uh what's his name
John come on that's your job that's what
you do you remember people's names Enoch
the actor oh the actor
Iman villani uh in my mind yeah it's
funny it's fondy Iman is fondy
um yeah
um I think he is excellent in this role
uh he seems like such a natural and he
doesn't
sometimes we become so aware when a
character from live act from animated is
is like on screen sure and here I just
feel like I'm just watching like he just
he fits he fits so well that I had a I
had a body moment for a second I was
like
yeah like he's just stacked good he's he
just pulls you in that well and I think
he even brings out a little bit more of
that charm with um the actress who plays
Speedway I think he pulls out the the
chemistry's there is good it's it's
helping big time yeah man I really
enjoyed his his work a lot here and I I
feel like there's a bigger power set of
him to be Unleashed but would you think
Mikhail well uh I think it was such a
smart decision and I give them so much
credit for not just like oh let's give
him a lightsaber now we've got like one
more like you know badass lightsaber
wielding Jedi
to to Really lean in on being in tuned
with the force and just to show us a
different kind of combat I mean that
moment when the force was just
messing up the lightsabers flow that
just like opens up so many storytelling
possibilities
um and also I just think really lends
itself to to Ezra as a whole uh in terms
of like the performance Ezra was such
like a goofy kid and had these like
wonderful moments of levity and you're
always worried about how is that going
to translate from animation to live
action and it felt so magical like
genuinely there was just like in the in
the midst of this like really intense
we're going back and forth between these
two hardcore battle scenes and a an
aerial fight and somehow like finds a
way to make me smile finds a way to make
me laugh uh and and captures that Ezra
charm but is also like matured it and
advanced it in a way that feels like
appropriate for his age and just also
appropriate for like where they're at in
the journey
[Music]
um you know and I I think
for Sabine
this is really the
like it's now or never you know for this
character I I think and uh I think we
saw a little bit of it today
um and like I know uh me being like stop
talking just like embrace the moment and
act like might come off as an insult but
I I also feel like you've you've spent
so much time talking building this up
let's just feel it and and and see it
like it I still feel like there's a lot
of and I and this part I'm gonna write
up to the script not necessarily the
acting but I feel like on sabine's part
there's just a lot more saying than
doing whereas everyone else is able to
convey a lot without saying this show is
better at doing than it is at talking
yeah and and that feeling than it is at
talking absolutely and and I feel like
it's it's been long enough now that like
we understand the Dynamics it should be
there I do think there was this really
lovely moment uh between Ahsoka and
Sabine just well actually I want to hear
what John thinks about Ezra before we
move on I don't think he really wants to
but he's being nice so come on John oh
okay like you don't you don't know Ezra
the way that I know Ezra this is the
justification this is true but I don't
know I mean sitting here again with the
more outside okay
uh no this brought me a lot of that
magic and excitement even for a
character yes I haven't spent as much
time with but between the context of
what they gave him the way they put him
into you know this familiar kind of
position in terms of like you know
various western movies it's like you
know so many kinds of movies where
you're trying to find you're doing a
search and rescue and you're finding
this person who's lived amongst the
natives and is kind of you know cobbled
together new abilities out of just you
know the situation around and from again
the the vague amounts of backstory I
know about this character you know this
is somebody with a more unorthodox
training often just out in the wild kind
of on his own so like this seems
appropriate to that and just having
these character interactions uh got me
just feeling that kind of butterfly
magic of just like oh this is this is
fun I feel like the release and the joy
of this reunion and I feel like his
presence has made Ahsoka uh uh um
sabine's presence better
their interactions I thought were really
fun and endearing and I liked the way
that even the sort of wagon train slash
train fight you know again very much in
the western movie tradition uh was like
fun and exhilarating but also was a
battle sequence that had a certain
amount of levity while not completely
issuing the immediate Stakes
um so yeah like I liked both the
physical elements of meeting Ezra here
and also
um yeah the actual character I just yeah
I mean imanas fondy has a lot of natural
charm and presence
um that I was quite effortlessly drawn
in by and now yeah I'm excited to spend
more time with his character to learn
more about this character etc etc and uh
and to have this guy in mind you know if
I were to go and and you know again
further
get all the backstory lore and
everything but I thought he was terrific
and and you know this is an episode
that's not without flaws but like in
terms of just enjoyment and all right
that's right he's the one who gave it a
nine you don't instead of an 8.5 yeah
on your point of this reminding you of a
lot of westerns
um it really does remind me of The Good
the Bad and the Ugly when John Wayne
Force chokes his opponents I feel like
there is
so I would love to I'd love to talk
about it
I would love to talk about if it's okay
if I pick the next subject yeah
uh we gotta make them faster seeing
thrawn
thrawn was really really nice I mean
there was like
show us how you get down
answers
so how do you take a character make them
really really interesting and involved
in the battle and all he's doing is
standing in front of like a hologram
chess board yeah he's like Ral Julia and
Street Fighter he's in my favorite movie
like John Wayne in the goodness
I'm just gonna say it so much I'm gonna
question if he's joking about it okay
does he actually think John Wayne is in
The Good The Bad and The Yoga
what is your view of Western Cinema
so
I'm really curious
good there's one
there's one episode left yeah yeah yeah
it's busy plus Russia don't worry about
it wrap it up
there's a lot to they're gonna kill him
next episode Kill Them All honestly I'll
tell you what I really wanted I wanted
thrawn to with all the the night
Troopers be like Execute Order 66 67 and
have that sure and like have them go and
try to kill right right well okay
uh speaking of thrawn I'm gonna lump him
into the action here yeah I like the
action yeah
um I think the action here was I thought
a lot of it was actually kind of
exhilarating if we're uh just to quickly
yeah no bigly it's just too the wrap up
the thing on like whatever it was cool
but soon Ezra and Sabine and then Ahsoka
fighting is you got three people who are
in in their own variations trained in
the art of the Jedi ways and you see
distinct fighting styles between the
three of them and I loved the aerial
fight scenes in the beginning the way
they would lock again like something I'm
often crediting here is the way they
lock on a perspective and keeping it
within the cockpit itself as you're
going through this as you I would feel
that in my heart as like I'm on a ride
with it so I I was caught up in the ride
of it all like it was so much fun and I
love the build up between uh Ahsoka and
thrawn eventually finally going to have
an encounter with each other and this
and the way the action ultimately
concludes it feels so much like an
episode of rebels to me where all right
look we got him we can go home but we
got one mission one more mission to do
before we can do that like it's such a
Rebels type of thing like and like we
survived but Ron's not done yet so we
need it we have to do this so I really I
thought the action itself was really
well orchestrated
um seeing Ahsoka I think if people were
might have been a little bit lost or
confused on on the arc that she
ultimately had she has come to this
place of acceptance where she couldn't
even like really reflect on the idea of
Anakin Skywalk Walker you know and now
she can revisit those memories like with
the Hologram with Hayden Christensen now
we can get non-stop cameos 19 more
specifically with those uh hologram and
recording decks and I don't know just
play a little bit at a time we can
really stretch those out if you're
listening I'll keep my Disney Plus
subscription if you release all of those
Holograms to us but like the way and
then she's like dual wielding and then
the way she's fighting uh there's such a
confidence and assuredness when she is
engaging in battle with Balin or Shin
she needed to whip out her lightsaber
when she was going up against shin and
there was no sense of fear uh when she
was fighting against balen she owned
that fight and she like left yes which
which is the lesson or a big part of
that lesson of you don't always have to
rush into Victory uh and I thought it
was interesting because Baylin was also
trying to teach that same lesson to his
Apprentice right Anakin was teaching the
same and you know ultimately that's the
same thing that Luke learned it wasn't
until Luke was like I don't need to win
this fight right now I need to put this
lightsaber down and ultimately that is
what's going to turn you know Anakin
back to the light exactly now the thing
though that I thought was a was kind of
disappointing oh boy which I did not
actually this is what brings it down
from a 10 to an 8.5 for me yeah is the
typical Star Wars thing yeah
um and maybe you guys can possibly
predict where I'm going with this does
anyone want to take a one sentence guess
the subject that I thought was actually
disappointing in this episode anyone
anyone I'll tell you everyone shut up
okay so last episode they teased these
death Troopers right yeah and I'm like
all right here we go this might be an
upgrade this might be something
worthwhile no maybe they've been told
oh my God people are like they might be
the reanimated it's like a stormtrooper
and walks like a stormtrooper it's a
storm and then even uh the when Balin
and shin encounter those like Samurai
looking uh Wanderers and like all right
they're gonna join forces with them and
uh they kind of just suck like oh and
they're on the battlefield like the the
naughty are messing them up uh they
don't seem like that hard they're just
numbers again they're just henchmen and
they're just whipping ass left and right
when the shelled Ewoks all right yeah
kick your butt it's just another large
quantity to to dish out uh combos on and
and to me that was the let down because
I'm like come on you kid another you
gotta cool because I kind of did that I
I think that DeLorean I think that's it
and it's just a Star Wars thing that
they often do is like oh cool quantity
of a cool new looking thing and it
ultimately amounts to well nothing and
maybe there'll be more who knows and I
think the shame of it is we know that
you can have a good version of that
because we've seen it with Troopers like
where there's like oh look at this like
formidable army that would also be nice
to like demonstrate I mean you have two
Jedi who I'd stare at the height of
their power and right a force-wielding
Mandalorian or a force attempting to
wield Mandalorian attempting the wheel
of forest Mandalorian uh
surely the three of them absolutely
wrecked like whatever came their way
regardless of you know how strong they
were it was nice to see Stormtroopers
like hit something for once though at
least they hit something yeah it would
just be nice if they could I don't know
yeah you have such a cool potential of
like what are these guys are they alive
are they you know imbued with witch
power like well when no green magic came
out of them that kind of did done that
theory yeah because because uh that that
thing that does shut down that theory
that they are because it's like whatever
their transport the cargo and maybe
that's maybe that's for the best like
perhaps I feel like if they're gonna do
that clearly they're saving it for the
cargo and it's going to be something
that's a lot bigger and a lot spookier
and you know uh I I do want to talk
briefly we should talk about the Hera
stuff before we wrap you know what yeah
because uh and I think you would
probably have some good takes on that
because I feel like I don't know how
that would amount like factor into the
finale unless they find their way to the
new Galax I'm like I don't know how it
seems like that they're gonna Reserve
that for us for for the future I I
thought it was a first off I just like
on a production design level something
that I've really appreciated
is that there is definitively I imagine
like an artistic temptation to kind of
because we're in the future of this
world to kind of go to a prequel like
style and instead they've really played
up the original like retro feel of the
Rebel Alliance and have kind of adapted
that to like a cleaner brighter
environment and like that whole meeting
room
felt like like a 1970s like it's like
United Nations like judicial they like
they captured the essence of the
original
aesthetic of the series uh while also
doing something interesting different
and I really appreciate it I I can't
uh I don't I can't agree with you I I
agree on what that's too I agree with
the onset production was doing but there
was something about the lighting and
cinematography that felt very Disney to
me yeah sure very well I think that's
the it's consistent with the tone of
what they've tried to make the new
Republic feeling yeah at the same time I
don't really like Vibe with that care
this was the first time more about the
context this was the first time that I
had started to get a little bit excited
mostly because C3PO showed up uh and
introducing Leia
honestly to me is becoming like really
really essential to weaving this all
together
um it's gonna be really uh tough call
man
well it's it is it is a tough call
they're gonna have to use it super
sparingly I think they should I I feel
like Star Wars has to learn to embrace
new casting
there's not much of it
I'm not sure all right well I I imagine
her daughter would probably uh play her
you know either way but what let's talk
let's focus on the on the on what
actually transpired there well I I think
that that you
if thrawn gets back to our galaxy as if
we own that Galaxy corus on you know the
main primary the fan Zone all the
primary Gap thank God you clarified if
thrawn makes it
planet Earth America USA where all the
descendants of the Stormtrooper that got
stuck here anyway Focus line I need you
to stay on
yeah
I think that if if something happens
it's going to be a fight ideally in the
unknown regions
um because if thrawn gets back the fact
that we haven't heard about it as we've
kind of like leaped forward like I don't
want them to just retcon this I don't
want this to be like a oh this happened
and it was over and that was done and by
the time that we get to the sequel
Trilogy it's irrelevant I kind of want
this larger threat and story to not
necessarily fully conclude and to take
us on a uh while all that other stuff is
going on this stuff is going on
um what does that look like
yeah I'm still holding out hope that
it's it's the risk and you know
but
I it's it's becoming harder for me to
think that they're going that direction
it seems like thrawn wants to come back
and Conquer
and which is
it's interesting because that doesn't
necessarily preclude the risk because
the grisker in the unknown regions which
is in the primary Galaxy
um
but that's also like a lot of stuff to
try to throw in an audience in one
episode have you seen um have you seen
um Indiana Jones at the dial Destiny no
okay no it came out well I'm gonna give
you guys I'm gonna give everyone here a
slight spoiler sorry you guys had a lot
of opportunities to check it out and
apparently not enough people did so I'm
gonna tell you it's not on Disney plus
yet
um
[Music]
he's like I can do it better than Hitler
that's my spoiler all right he's like he
was a Nazi and he's like but I can do it
better than Hitler yeah that's kind of
the impression that I feel like his
brother Lars Mickelson is doing here is
I can do it better than where the
emperor failed yeah you know and and
that's what I'm smarter and more cunning
yeah well the only challenge with that
is that
Palpatine's still alive I know somehow
somehow but there but he's got the I
want to see how the dark magic gets more
implemented because the last episode
they had that tease too with like
sisters I'm gonna need your magic and
then I'm like okay I should just kind of
use it to look we're so good I thought
it was gonna be like something with the
battles you know um and uh I would just
find my iPhone yeah so well something
something did occur to me
um
obviously like a lot of people on the
internet are talking about like the
zepho glyphs that were seen
um there are like zepho temples on
dathomir they want to make the most
sense if that's what baylen's looking
for
the zepho something to do with the
Zephyr
maybe I mean it would make sense because
because ultimately like and context for
those that have no idea what the hell
this is for this for uh an ancient
species of force-wielding aliens uh that
left behind a lot of ruins including on
dathomir which is where the the Knight
sisters ultimately settled
um they
turn to the dark side and destroyed
themselves from within and a few
survivors escaped to the unknown regions
and arguably to this other Galaxy yeah
and then someone found online like those
people have found online like one of the
rooms they if you flip it upside down
it's actually it's definitely yeah which
isn't surprising I mean that that
connective thread makes sense is like a
force-wheeling species
um you know I'm and there's been like so
much of in like Jedi Survivor and stuff
so I I I really I'm holding very firmly
to that this season is going to end with
Balin Shen Ahsoka Ezra and Sabine all on
the same side and all of them represent
such fascinating different aspects of
a balanced force sure
um yeah and once they realize that
thrawn and the Knight sisters and
everything that they're doing runs
counter to keeping that balance
um I think you're gonna see something
really different and really interesting
yeah
um you know I'm I'm just increasingly
curious and concerned because of the
lack of time that we have but also we
need to remember
this is leading up to a cinematic event
this is leading up to a film and that
film is going to be so confusing for
people I I do feel that's that's what I
know about that film yeah I'm gonna love
it but nobody's gonna know what's
happening it's John get the final
thoughts in here no yeah it's just weird
to take these shows in because
especially knowing that that we're
leading to these bigger and bigger
things like this like you asked what the
f what I would rate this episode at the
beginning and it's fascinating because
you got to kind of think of it both ways
because
we didn't really care dude no I don't
think you did I'm using that as an
example just to say that like this is
these Series this series as well are
fascinating to take in because the whole
does feel still kind of like odd and
disjointed and like we're still just
about to start something and then like
within that individual episodes can
exemplify all the potential that is at
hand but sitting here I'm like as much
as I enjoyed this episode have greatly
enjoyed the past couple especially I'm
like I don't know I write it all a
satisfying conclusion to this season
that feels proportionate and that also
feels like you know you're leaving
potential open but it's not just stuff
that you could have explored now if you
didn't waste time yeah like this episode
exemplifies still that weird you know
tension this show has between like
talking and when they do talk a lot of
times they're not really saying that
much and then oftentimes it's to the
actors to the performances to really
kind of give you the hints the greater
things lie beneath and behead and ahead
um so yeah I am trepidatious going into
the end because like I like a lot of
these episodes individually but as like
holes and this has been a thing across
these shows as holes they are kind of
odd and disjointed feelings sure yeah
um whatever I'm excited for finale guys
alrighty are we good
well sabine's gonna reconnect with the
mandalorians I've got it and upload and
thumb this video is there anything more
you gotta say hurry it up didn't yarn
already has a pre-existing relationship
with the Stoka I think you have Luke and
Leia who are connected and I think
you're looking at space Avengers yeah
hey that's all it is guys that's all we
need team alrighty well thank you both
for being here I had nowhere else to be
and um hey before we go let's add a
little Star Wars wipe all right we're
gonna shop Brian Perry Oh AI style
people
all right okay so
um all right I'll do a Mad Libs game
um Michael give me an adjective
running uh I guess that's yep tactically
yeah yeah John you give me a different
adjective oh purple purple all right uh
give me an occupation Runner
get more creative a proctologist this is
why I exist Michael
practitioner
proctologists I love it all right give
me a uh a time in history Michael ER the
Second Punic Wars Second Punic Wars all
right uh give me your favorite celebrity
John oh easily Harry Styles Harry Styles
okay Michael give me a Star Wars weapon
uh a Star Wars weapon I think we're
looking at
oh boy you know let's just go
let's just go with uh qui-gon's
lightsaber Qui-Gon gin lightsaber all
right last thing
um let's give me a um an article of
clothing a loincloth loincloth that's
what I'm talking about people okay here
we go
I have a YouTube channel where I need to
do some chat DVT people where I need to
shout out a patron who might call a
super sexy reject his name is Brian
Perry yes it is
give him a shout right uh write me a
shout out in under 50 words that
incorporates these words
this is the greatest oh my God all right
all right uh John take it away big shout
out to our super sexy reject Brian Perry
he's running through life in a purple
loincloth like a proctologist during the
Second Punic Wars wielding a Qui-Gon
Shin lightsaber and rocking Vibe
smoother than Harry Styles thanks for
the Epic support Brian you rock Brian
I like this just literally just created
a character yeah I was like I'm just
gonna put these words in order I am I'm
not gonna lie we're so screwed no we're
not this is there are literal AI in Star
Wars it's fitting yeah and we're running
out of ideas frankly and that's when you
turn
to chat gbt now that the writer strike
is over it all else fails
Brian we love you so much